I will just do a sound check what did
you have for breakfast this morning for
breakfast I had a cup of coffee with two
shots and heavy cream and actually a an
Americano with two shots of coffee and
heavy cream and I had a smoothie with
apple and yogurt and some [ __ ] and that
well we will talk more about the [ __ ]
part that that's it's gonna be very very
relevant at this altitude this episode
is brought to you by athletic greens I
get asked all the time if you could only
use one supplement what would it be and
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
god 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out it's
tasty but more important it will help
you not screw up when you're doing your
nutritional planning so for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind
puts a lot in my body and check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
Pro which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers Airbnb
Etsy etc why do they use it well Vimeo
Pro provides enterprise level video
hosting for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week
unlimited plays and views and a fully
customizable video player which can
include your logo custom outro etc you
also get VIP support and you get all of
this for just $1.99 per year that's $17
a month with no complicated bandwidth
calculations or hidden fees and you can
try it risk-free for 30 days so check it
out Vimeo comm forward slash business
that's VI m EO com forward slash
business and use promo code Tim to get
25% off that's a special discount just
for you guys so check it out Vimeo com
forward slash business promo code Tim
hello my little kittens this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where I attempt
in each interview to deconstruct
world class performers to tease out the
things you can use not just act with
integrity but what does that actually
mean on a daily basis what are your
morning routines what are your habits
what are your favorite books what are
your influences what are your favorite
documentaries so on and so forth I
really want specific tactics that you
guys can apply tool kits that you can
use in your daily life and lives
that's a plural for you guys and this
episode is no exception I'm very excited
to have Sophia Amoruso that's at Sofia
underscore Emma Russo on the show she is
founder and executive chairman of Nasty
Gal which is a global online destination
for both new and vintage clothing shoes
and accessories among many other things
founded in 2006 Nasty Gal was named
fastest-growing retailer in 2012 by inc
magazine thanks I suppose in part to its
eleven thousand two hundred percent 3
year growth rate it's a very big number
so if
has been called to quote fashions new
phenom unquote by Forbes magazine and
she has become one of the most prominent
and iconic figures in retail she
recently founded hashtag girl boss
foundation which Awards financial grants
to women in the world of design fashion
and music
Sophia's first book hashtag girl boss
check it out is a New York Times best
seller published in 15 countries and we
touch upon many many things we talk
about tactics testing the Genesis story
of Nasty Gal
early successes early mistakes the last
time she accidentally crapped in her
pants we really go all over the place
and there is a lot of personality in
this episode there's a lot of fun and
there's also a lot that you can use so
without further ado please enjoy this
conversation with Sophia Amoruso
Sofia welcome to the show hi Tim how are
you I am I'm fantastic
and we've had such an adventure putting
this together and getting all the tech
to work but I'm stoked to be chatting
with you I've wanted to have a jam
session with you for so long and I know
we've met very briefly before but let's
let's start with some basics for people
who may not be familiar with you and I
know your role has changed in the last
year or so but when people ask you what
do you do how do you answer that now and
how did you answer that two years ago if
I don't know them I just say like I have
an online fashion business and I try to
leave it at that and if they ask it
depends on who it is but I started a
company called Nasty Gal in 2006 as an
eBay store selling vintage clothing and
you know whatever like a lot of
entrepreneurs just did everything myself
did what needed to happen just ran a
little eBay store but it it wasn't
little for very long left eBay about a
year and a half later and launched Nasty
Gal calm which is now kind of a full-on
fashion ecommerce destination we carry
brands we design our own product and we
still sell vintage and I guess I'm an
author so there's that to you I wrote a
book last year that spent a bunch of
time on the on the bestseller list and
it was called girlboss it's called
hashtag girlboss but saying hashtag out
lads kind of weird entity I mean you're
a multi - it you've done a lot to put
some numbers or stats to it and I'm
reading off of just the reading that
I've done so I'd love for feel free to
correct me but it sounds like company
has customers in more than 60 countries
it was the fastest growing retailer in
2012 correct ink magazine and I guess at
one point at least it sounds like an
again I'm reading from online so who
knows how verified this is but I guess
in 2011 when it was started in 2006 and
by 2011
revenue is like 24 million or so marking
I guess an eleven thousand plus three
year growth rate so very impressive
stuff Thanks
very impressive and the I have to I
cannot resist asking about some of these
bullets before we get into that whole
story I apologize in advance so for
those who are wondering how this podcast
gets put together I usually like to not
not rehearse but send some prompts for
guests or on the show so one of the
sentences that I send out is can you
please send some bullets with a handful
of topics and her question that will
lead to actionable tips advice comma
funny stories comma or resource and
how-to recommendations so funny stories
the first I just I just straight for
funny story no it was so I'm just gonna
read the first five and then we're gonna
dig into one so bullet number one I once
pooped my pants in high school we're
gonna come back to that number two I
have three poodles that are all related
number three and I'm paraphrasing here I
lived on a street called called orange
blossom twice in different parts of
California I love karaoke
and look the than the the last bill I'll
read is I'm a big supporter of reality
TV because it's cheaper and healthier
than weed or alcohol
people love the embarrassing stories I
woke up this morning for the first time
I just adopted a rescue puppy about six
weeks ago she's five months old I woke
up and she's never pooped in the house
and woke up and she she's being crate
trained and looking at the crate it
looked like someone had taken a handful
of mud and thrown it into a Cuisinart
she somehow managed to diarrhea in every
direction including on the top of the
cage I don't know how this is possible
yeah yeah unless you're like a Cirque de
Soleil athlete who's had whatever tumors
should drink but in any case so this is
on the mind obviously that's all cleaned
up she's fine she's chillin Molly's good
but tell me about this this high school
incident I have to I have to ask since
we sent over oh my god well I was at
this guy's house I was like 16 years old
I was at this guy's house who was like
some a
using bassists he played this thing
called a war guitar which is based it's
like a it's like a bass with I don't
know a ton of strings on it and you it's
you basically just play the fret board
and he was just looking it's weird like
proggy
musician who I thought was super cool
and he was like I don't know maybe he
was like 19 I thought that was amazing
and I went to his house he like lived
with his dad and got there like I don't
after like 15 minutes my stomach was
just like oh I had eaten some some
pepperoni pizza I think like the kind
that has cheese that you can almost
drink like not nothing not like you know
not like boutique e la Fitte or whatever
it's like it was like it was like gnarly
pepperoni pizza just like mouthfuls of
cheese anyway I was like oh no I don't
wanna use this guy's bathroom I'm not
sure what's going on here but I should
probably leave so after like 15 minutes
at his house I I left and I started
driving down the street it wasn't like
oh geez well if I had a Toyota then I'll
be happy about it was like oh I really
need a toilet and I stopped at this
liquor store and walked inside and I was
like do you guys have a restroom I can
use and they were like no sorry it's for
employees only
I thought aged it would have been
confusing if I had like lied and said I
was pregnant I've done that before um
once only an awful person
and then so I got back in my car and
drove I was in a like 1991 Honda Civic
with a little like like a little like
like a racing steering wheel it was
pretty funny and I drove down the street
and stopped at a gas station
and got out and it was like step step
Frank I'm just like oh my I didn't even
make it inside and it was just like you
know when something like that happens to
you
you wonder if you're gonna spend the
rest of your life doing that like
uncontrollably because it's so shocking
like it just shouldn't happen and and I
I just like I had to get back in my car
and like finish like finish
and then I had to drive home and you
know sitting in my in my I'm sorry
that's that's that's my pitch I
apologize for that
but so you see casting story I had so so
that number of friends who swap stories
sorry my dog's freaking out guys
ok this is like podcast Verity are you
there yeah ok coming back to the topic
at hand so I have a number of friends
who are athletes and I've been
competitive athletes and guys take all
sorts of disgusting pre-workout products
and so on and these guys trade stories
of what they call fouling out so what
happened to you they would call fouling
out oh my god no you're not alone and so
I'll trade of just a really quick one
because I think that most guys who have
tried to gain muscle and taken a lot of
horrible supplements will somehow
identify with this so I was on my way
driving on my way to SFO right driving
to the airport and I had had a bunch of
creatine monohydrate a bunch of coffee
and then I think what's called MCT oil
which is the ultimate recipe for
disaster pants I now realize in
retrospect but got halfway to the
airport I'm racing to a flight and had
the exact experience that you did comply
dish viciously shat myself it's like
it's like throwing up it comes in waves
oh it was the worst like throwing up so
then I had to basically I clean myself
up with my own boxers and like right
into the airport get through security
and then go deal with myself but so for
those people out there have had this
experience you're not alone and that
what you said also like this steps kind
of like step step bang it made me think
of like San Francisco doula midwifery
and whatnot because they're like oh and
you're trying to have a natural birth if
you're doing it at home you can have a
pregnant woman like walk on a curb
hey just like one foot on one foot off
and that's a one way to like kind of pop
the baby out so Wow you know all kinds
of stuff well before our baby
the forever baby sounds like a horrible
tragedy but how did the business start
now in yeah I and I think a lot of
people know they know you they know your
photograph they've seen the book they're
very familiar with the company as it
exists now but like what was the what
was the moment in which you decided to
start selling clothing yeah I never
worked in the clothing store and it
wasn't you know the eBay was definitely
not my way into the fashion industry
that was not my intention i I just was
kind of flailing I wanted to be a
photographer but I figuring out how to
like moves in the art world or talk
about my photography and make stuff up
about why it was important or all of
that stuff just seemed like not right
for me and not like people were inviting
me to do shows although I did have a
show at Adobe books before they went
extinct do you ever go there no this is
this is here in the Bay Area
yeah I was a supercool bookstore in San
Francisco but I don't know I was like
working at the Academy of Art University
in downtown San Francisco
how old were you at that point I was 22
okay I got it and I got that job because
I needed to have a hernia fixed I don't
know how I got a hernia but I had no
health insurance so I had to get a job
so I could get health insurance so I
could get my hernia fixed and I had to
work at this job for three months to get
health insurance so I did but I was
working in the lobby just like checking
student IDs and sometimes worked like
late at night and was you know had time
to kill on the internet and was getting
friend requests on MySpace I'm not sure
if anyone remembers and so it's getting
friend requests on myspace from eBay
sellers that were promoting their
businesses on myspace and I wore almost
entirely vintage at the time and I knew
where to find it and I saw the prices
that these vintage pieces were fetching
on eBay and said hey you know I could
find them for way cheaper I know how to
take a picture pretty sure I know how to
use the Internet and eBay eBay was a
great place to start you know there's a
kind of like a framework for you to sell
online and it's really easy today but
then building a website like a webshop
wasn't you know it wasn't as easy so
started with eBay and you also have a
built in customer base there you put
something and you can test you can test
like what works or if people like your
tastes you know your tastes or what you
have to bring to the table so I bought
you BAE for dummies and had a friend
model for free you know and just found
some vintage sold some of my stuff and
it was you know you can get a read on
what people like really really quickly
on eBay because they watch stuff wait
there's something called watching which
is basically like you're you like
monitoring it or adding to your
favorites who want to see what happens
with the auction over the course of a
week or ten days and how did you know
where to find vintage clothing I it was
like all I wore so I just I'd spent I've
just spent my youth in thrift stores
like discovering just unearthing stuff
that no one else wanted that I thought
was really special and then I made a
career out of it did you have a favorite
thrift store at the time in the Bay Area
um we think at the time oh I don't know
none of them are just none of them are a
real like gold mine anymore
well I like to state fails a lot because
you can encounter people have no idea
what they have that that's becoming a
rarer and rarer and thrift stores are
like onto vintage being valuable how
would you find at the time how would you
find the estate sales just look in the
newspaper or like a Craigslist I'm not a
mom charge a craigslist in the newspaper
yeah and I like line up with all these
people that were I don't know way older
than me like 6:00 a.m. should be the
first people in and I just run straight
for the closet and hope whoever died had
great style its I saw this
the end I didn't watch I didn't see the
entire thing my girlfriend was watching
at the end of this documentary about 8th
I want to say fashion icon named iris
who's now or when it was recorded or
filmed and her 90s 93 and she has
awesome style but I think it'll be hard
to get to her estate still yeah so you
got it you get eBay for dummies you know
where to find the vintage clothing know
how to take a picture what and and
you're getting an indication of what
works or what people are at least
interested in right through the watching
what was do you remember your first sale
or your first day of sales yeah it was
like well it was a it was it was a week
of auction so I watch what happened over
the course of the week and at the very
end some stuff goes crazy because people
swoop in at the last minute trying to
steal it from whoever was in the lead
and you know sometimes nothing happens
but I learned really quickly what you
know what was working and what wasn't
and tweaked that you know every with
every auction with everything I I bought
and I watched my competitors and I watch
what they were doing and I just I try to
do a better job and I don't know what
what what are some examples of maybe
some of the things that you noticed in
those initial tests and that you could
be better at yeah well the thumbnails
are the thing that attract that the
evening you you evaluate everything as
you browse eBay buy a thumbnail and the
title of the item and those are two
things that you can optimize just into
kind of infinity I mean there's a
limited amount of space but I knew that
using images that were really bright
where you could see the silhouette of
the item eBay thumbnails have gotten a
lot bigger but at the time they were
teeny tiny teeny tiny so making it
really obvious with the what the item
was and even showing you know I had a I
would split the image in half and have
you know half of the thumbnail be a full
like a full-length shot of the item and
then I'd have like a detail shot like on
them maybe the right hand side
and the description so I mean the
selling vintage is such an incredible
way to learn perceived value because
unless you're selling something that's
like a designer like a Chanel jacket or
whatever you're buying stuff that you're
buying it for the style and you're
buying things that have no inherent
value that could be that all really are
someone else's throwaway and exalting
them to a level that makes them worth
more and and worth more I mean even a
was the customer who determined the
price I started everything at $9.99 and
let them choose I'll let them fight over
it but only they only fought over it
because I turned it into something
really special and I breathed new life
into these forgotten about thing and
what we're mean as a as a copywriter
well how did you accomplish that and and
maybe that's a nonspecific question
that's unhelpful I'm just first for
instance I mean a lot of people bring up
I think it's influenced by Robert Cal
Dini and they talk about say you know
scarcity time restrictions ha ha etc as
tools of persuasion that can be used for
for good or ill means but what did you
how did you learn to write persuasive
copy I don't know my mom was a writer
and write reading and writing was always
I mean it sounds like so so basic but it
was just something that she always took
a lot of pride in and something that I
really cared about and I guess I had a
voice I didn't realize that until later
on when I read you know when I realized
I was building a brand because there
were so many specific things that were
had become part of the nasty y'all DNA
but you can take something that may be
like an 80s like big ass you know coat
KP thing that you know some you know
overweight lady might have bought and
turn it into like this like avant-garde
I mean you can use words like
avant-garde for something that could be
perceived as like outdated and funky on
the wrong person like a lady with a perm
or just like the coolest thing on some
like kid with a weird haircut
you know on the sidewalk so it's all
about context right yeah so a couple of
things the first is thumbnails we are
doing this over Skype for those people
who always ask me I'm using ECAM call
recorder to record this and
audio-technica ATR 2100 mic which is
about 60 bucks on Amazon but your
thumbnail for Skype is this rad looking
chick I don't know who she is it's a
bunch of bikers naked female bikers and
one of them has it looks like a tattoo
of flowers and something over one breast
and she's holding a knife I can try tell
exactly what's going on where's this
from how did you so I'm I'm working on
I'm working on my second book and I've
been like pulling images there's all
kinds of inspiration some of it will be
used in the book and this is actually an
image from a movie called girl boss girl
boss gorilla gorilla gue yeah yeah yeah
so that was a film that I saw a long
time ago that was kind of the
inspiration for the name of girl boss
and very few people know that
um so these there's a whole genre of
Japanese like cinema called pinky
violence or just pinky films and it's
pretty much like all female revenge and
like girl gangs and they're so cool like
they're super stylish and Tarantino's
ripped a lot from them and this this one
this is from girl boss gorilla I wonder
if I think Battle Royale I want to say
is one of those comic books sort of like
the most violent violent things you
could possibly imagine which makes you
then think if some of say the fight
scenes in like Kill Bill in some
capacity but coming back to the writing
for a second well let me start with a
question that I always ask and we'll go
from there what is the book that you've
gifted most to other people so the book
that I've gifted most other people is
the richest man in Babylon which I
talked about in girlboss and it's was
written like a hundred years ago and
it's it's written as though it was
written in biblical times or something
parables
oh yeah it's parable or yeah it would be
a parable it'd be like The Alchemist
yeah it's like it's basically parable
set in ancient times describing someone
who goes about this guy who goes about I
forget his name trying to find out how
he can make money how can you make a
life for himself and his family and he
encounters all these different people
and lessons along the way and the advice
is you know Barry there's some really
simple advice like save 10% of
everything that you earn don't take
advice from the Baker if you want to be
a cobbler you know yeah um and it's
something that anyone can read and
understand it's like oh it's like a 1
hour to hour read it's the tiniest
little book and a hundred years later
all the advice still holds up which I
find really great and it's like a it's a
cheap book and I'm a cheap giver so I'm
kidding I'm kidding
so it would be that it would be that in
my book I guess the the richest man in
Babylon and what what other writers just
from writing perspectives he said you're
using your mother was writer or your
father my mom yeah what's what type of
writing did she do well she sold houses
for a long time and then kind of quit
doing that and started writing about
real estate and now she writes about all
kinds of stuff and she's working on her
own book but it yeah wait what was the
question the question was I was I was
stuttering and stammering my way to the
question which was what you have any
favorite writers our writers that you
admire of influenced you any of the
above yeah so Rainer Maria Rilke I think
it's just such a great can you see that
one more time please I think it's Rainer
Maria Rilke oh yeah yeah yeah yeah um so
on love and other what's it called on
love another maybe it's just on love
I don't know everything I read almost
like everything that I
learned from actually reading things or
unearthing culture happened before I
started the business because after
basically since I was 22 so it's been
almost a decade I feel like my personal
I don't know my quest for for-4
knowledge was fulfilled by all the [ __ ]
all the challenges that come with
building a business and so things like
books that I read for fun and not books
that I read to learn stuff kind of went
out the door right it's like all
nonfiction the discretionary
extracurricular has kind of got consumed
or displaced by the work kind of yeah
it's like I only read things that I can
do something practical with now just I
don't know not not something that makes
for a lot of relaxation but fun it's a
Rainer Maria Rilke if that's I'm sure
I'm pronouncing that incorrectly but
he's come up actually in my life in the
last 48 hours I've had two separate
people recommend reading and I did read
this long long time ago but letters to a
young poet was from 1929 so what do you
do you said it's not relaxing and I know
we're hopping around a lot but what do
you do to relax let's just say looking
back at some of the either tougher
periods or fastest-growing periods in
your company what did you do to
decompress I mean when you felt
overwhelmed or burned out what did you
do how did you manage that God sometimes
you just kind of explode hopefully no
one else is around you know I was like I
was like crying last night also why are
you crying last night I can't let they
go oh my god I don't know just because
because running a business is really
hard
uh-huh and wouldn't ya what do you do I
mean do you cry for like five minutes
and you're done do you cry for longer
than that do you yeah I cried for like
five minutes and then I was done she's
kind of like this feels good so I'm
gonna just let it happen Chris I can't
yeah yeah just like [ __ ] it was just one
of those
was the long day yeah but right now the
thing that relaxes me the most is tuning
in and turning off with reality TV I
don't know I just finished watching the
entire season of the worst show it's not
the people are not even compelling
they're like a not funny it it's it's so
bad but it you can't stop watching it's
called dating naked dating naked oh my
god I've seen I remember I saw a few
minutes of this in like a waiting room
at a doctor or something and I was like
that is the most ridiculous premise I've
ever seen but I couldn't stop watching
it it's so dumb so dumb but I can't you
can't stop watching you're like oh
they're buds and you're like but I was
like watching a show I don't know yeah
what else do I do to relax hang out with
my dogs they're cool these are these are
the three poodles that are related
they're all siblings yeah they're
different ages they're like from
different litters but their parents like
yeah their parents have been busy what
are they what are their names
Donna Summer is the oldest one and she's
like three and the next one's cozy dozer
and cozies like I don't know maybe just
over a year old and then there's one
named Gino who was named after my
husband's grandfather and he's like I
don't know maybe eight months or so
that's Gino I I want to think about
naming because naming and titling is
really
I've enjoyed reading about how you've
gone about it in a few cases so the
girlboss gorilla I have no idea so
that's new and I need to get that made
into a poster in my house because it's
amazing and second so Gina's after the
grandfather what about the two other
dogs how did you come up with those
names or how were they named I don't
know Donna it was just like well was
kind of like can we name her dawn a
bummer and then it was like but that's
not very nice okay let's and then they
were Donna Summer I don't know I don't
know why so she's a cool haircut and
then
Cosi it was just like super sleepy and
you know when we brought Donna home she
was like screaming her head off just
like don't take me away from my parents
and they're like oh no we're awful then
we brought cozy home and cozy just like
kind of slept theirs it was just like
I'm cool and she's still like that
so it's just like let's let's name her
cozy dozer
cozy dozer no nasty gal mm-hmm
this is people a lot of folks don't know
the origin where is the name from so the
name nasty gal so I used to work at a
record store in San Francisco that's no
longer around in Noe Valley called
streetlight records and spent a lot of
time I think music was probably like my
first love way before fashion I'm not
even sure if I'm in love with fashion
and this I'm not sure if it was just
reissued at that time I somehow
uncovered this album called
nasty out by a woman named Betty Davis
who I think is becoming become more
well-known but she's the ex-wife of
Miles Davis and she's just like super
outspoken punk singer with a really
great band behind her and just a super
broad she like awesome lyrics and she
just doesn't give a [ __ ] so when I was
choosing a name for my eBay store which
I never thought I'd be you know I never
thought I'd be talking about it this
much you know nine years later he's just
fine I still like the name I thought I
thought Nasty Gal would be good because
there was so many other eBay sellers who
whose business names were like ladies
standing in the dust or you know like
they're like lady and tall grass or like
boho just like so like bohemian and kind
of like expected and I was like I'm
gonna name it nasty cow I don't know I'm
just like I'm an eminent agonistic I
don't know it worked
what and in looking back at Nasty Gal I
guess a couple of questions one is said
I've read in different places well
different accounts of this why why leave
eBay what what yeah one second did I
actually say that she's an album called
nasty gal cuz I think I didn't cuz I
think I just talked about this lady
named Betty Dave
all right well that that's helpful to
have that tidbit then so the album name
is Nasty Gal hence yes bang okay cool
the transition off of ebay how did that
how did that happy what's the what's the
story behind that well it wasn't much of
a transition you know I like to make
promises that I'm not sure I can keep
and then figure out how to keep them top
three times in my life we will come back
to that I think you can like will things
into happening by just like committing
to them sometimes and so I was started
started to promote the idea of this you
know coming soon Nasty Gal calm Nasty
Gal vintage calm was actually the first
URL ID by Nasty Gal calm from you can
guess who but I started to leave
feedback for my customers when wait a
second alright I actually can't guess
I'm like Bette Davis I can't imagine
that's who know who did you have to buy
ever owned was a some company yes did
you do that through a broker did you
reach out to them directly or I did it
through a broker got it and where does
someone find such a broker to help them
if they want to do that I don't remember
someone introduced me to this guy and it
was like it was $8,000 nice that's a
good investment right there yeah so I
started interrupt but I had to that my
head was spinning with all these
incorrect answers so you get the domain
you've put up coming soon doing yeah
coming soon you know Nasty Gal vintage
and I had started to leave feedback for
my customers on eBay saying like hey
come come - coming soon STL vintage calm
and I was like oh [ __ ] I better build a
website better actually do this so I
figured out I launched the website and
when I launched the website eBay decided
to suspend me around the same time so it
was not a transition it was literally
like I'm gonna try this website thing I
hope I can go back to eBay if it doesn't
work out but it was very it became
apparent pretty quickly that that wasn't
gonna be an option I got suspended for
leaving a URL in the feedback for the
customers
you baby doesn't want to send they don't
want you sending traffic off their
website yeah ixnay on the stealing our
customers a God so what the hell did you
do I mean if if suddenly BAM yeah that
entire ecosystems turned off what
happened in the next it's kind of like
24-48 hours I I had well some people
some some editors had heard or seen on
the myspace profile that I was gonna
launch a website and they did a little
coverage of it when they when it when it
launched and it launched it was just
kind of like there was a lot of pent up
demand I had I didn't know I had would
have any traffic but the website sold
out just instantly it was like an hour
and there was maybe a hundred and fifty
items on the website when we launched
but there's only one of each of those
things there's one of a kind you just
150 order still seems like a lot for
your birthday of doing business but it
was just like I had like Kelly Ripa's
stylist calling me asking if I had
another one of those like extra snows in
it like vintage jacket and extra small
it's like no it's one-of-a-kind and I
don't know it was it was very
serendipitous that it worked at all and
that you know I I was able to not have
to go back to eBay but even a sentence
comment no I agree I think we can work
without punctuation in this conversation
okay yeah
especially since I've had enough enough
tea now and butter and coconut oil to to
last me further like a Siberian Trek but
I'm digressing the ebay transition slash
booting off of slash jump ain't jumping
headfirst and growing wings on the way
down that was how long after you started
selling on eBay that was oh gosh a year
and a half and at the at the point that
you launched your site
what did sales look like on eBay for you
if you recall yeah so the first year on
eBay was like 75,000 in revenue which
you know I wasn't paying myself I mean I
didn't need stuff I lived in a pool
house
for $500 a month like I drove at 87
Volvo like I didn't eat Boston Market
and subway you know like all the time so
it was that was like winning a lottery
yeah for sure I think Boston Market is
underrated I used like Trader Joe's in
Boston markets like don't knock it until
you try it and then you start getting
these enquiries from say Kelly Ripa
stylist she is extra small having been
on that show on she is tiny that's great
she is an amazing shape
how did you develop those relationships
with editors and so on or was it all out
of the blue I mean did you ping them no
it was like totally inbound at that
point and it wasn't like a giant you
know there wasn't a ton of news
everywhere it was daily candy you know
rest in peace and who what where and
they just kind of they'd they followed
me on MySpace they heard about the
launch and they decided to talk about it
and the kind of coverage I got was stuff
that brands like Cartier will pay you
know tens of thousands of dollars you
know for but when you're doing something
cool people want to talk about it and I
guess it was climbing I hate chalant
saying that I'm cool but you can say it
was cool because if you were like let me
tell you how I'm cool it would be one
thing but you're talking about how the
how the the launch was cool that's
people liked it they liked it so they
talked about it if you have something
great people will talk about it I think
that's just kind of like a rule of the
Internet and if someone were launching
now not necessarily fashion or anything
like that but they say I have this idea
for X let's just let's we can think
something up like vintage toy cars let's
just say mm-hmm I'm sure it's been done
but and they say you know I would like
to figure out I would like to build a
business based on this what what advice
would you give them in terms of kind of
testing or de-risking or testing the
waters in any way
or you can answer that in any way really
that you'd like but if you had that
conversation with someone and I'm sure
you have had probably ad nauseam these
types of conversations but now assuming
they're pretty smart they're willing to
do the work they're detail-oriented like
what would you say to them I would say
it's it's really great to test your
product I'm my mo is like I'm gonna talk
about something before I've even
launched it make a big stink of a thing
that I'm not you know who knows if it's
going to work out and that's just just
me being kind of like short attention
span instant gratification but I really
think there's a lot of value and and
being patient in testing things with
like a small group before you go out
there and tell the world tada
you know here I am fully formed you know
buy into my stuff you know buy into what
I'm doing I think there's just a lot of
resources for I mean it's as far as
selling online goes it's I mean it's
like having a lemonade stand at this
point so it's incredibly easy thing to
do your product should be really
differentiated and the way you talk
about it should be unique and it's
really thoughtful and regardless of
whether you're selling you know use
diapers or use toy cars sorry you you
should you should you should really
really invest in presenting yourself
well and there's websites like
Squarespace obviously that that make up
so easy now so much easier than it used
to be just finding a graphic designer
that could make something look like what
you can plug into now for almost no
money is is incredible ya know the the
infrastructure I mean the the rentable
infrastructure per se whether it's a
Squarespace or WordPress or someone else
I mean you can you can have a site up
and running
within an hour or two and then you could
use you know I've mentioned them in the
4-hour workweek but even the
marketplaces that exist now for things
like designers writer illustrators like
a 99 designs or Fiverr or something like
that I mean I'm having no illustrations
done for a book right now with the non
spec version of
designs these kind of one-on-one
projects and the quality is obscenely
high I mean I've been very very
impressed so it is a lot easier in
particularly with things like
Kickstarter I think you have also the
ability to see how strong your pitches
right before you buy inventory or
manufacture things yeah no one cares you
don't have a customer and so you got to
see if anyone cares first exactly and if
they're willing to part ways with their
dollars what were some books or
resources that helped you in the first
few years or overall build in building
Nasty Gal
early um I would say I would say and the
dummies guides are not I mean they're
fine they're really fine when I went to
raise venture capital there's one called
he had something like how to be smarter
than your venture capitalist like
literary for something like that and I
thought and I was like you know I've
raced seventy million dollars so I guess
I figured that out and there was a book
called no man's land that I thought was
really good it was about just that
period of time or you're too small to be
big and you're too big to be small and
most people hire middle management but
middle management have never seen the
top so then you hire more senior
management and I've done that and even
that's challenging so I mean there's no
silver bullet but reading other people
reading about other people's experiences
of growing and struggling with scaling a
business always makes you feel better
um is the book that you were thinking of
venture deals be smarter than your
lawyer and venture capitalists know
maybe it's called like how to outsmart
your venture capitalist or something how
to train your venture capitalists yeah
how to be smarter than your venture
capitalists that's what it's called
at least that's what's coming up in the
search results let me see how to be
smarter than your venture capitalists
you know Oh venture deals be smarter
than your lawyer I guess that's it yeah
okay
all right cool yeah that venture deals
for people interested in this world is
is a great book that's Brad Feld and his
partner very very good investors what
what were some of the biggest challenges
for scaling and e-commerce business what
were some of the harder things that you
guys that you had to contend with let's
just let's just keep it focused on you
but the company of course as it's
growing and I've spoken with people like
Phil Libin have Evernote on the podcast
and he's like well like this you know
gent who runs Rakuten he's saying you
should always plan on like what if it's
three times bigger what if it's ten
times bigger they're sort of these phase
shifts where where systems have to be
completely redone but for for you and
growing the company what were some of
the what were some of the hardest
periods for you yeah I would say scaling
is really hard so it's a infrastructure
so systems I mean we still don't have
the systems that we would like to have
to be able to plan our business and
evaluate our business and talk about it
what will be some examples systems I
mean it's really kind of like
unglamorous stuff like an ERP system
like enterprise resource planning which
basically connects the dots between you
know different departments like finance
and you know merchandise and whatever
else in right now everything that we do
is living in kind of disparate systems
that don't talk as much as they could um
so that's that's a struggle today what
else and you know I would say people I
would say like you know being having
never really been a manager prior to
starting the business that is Nasty Gal
you know my dream scenario one point was
you know it was not getting out of a
bathroom an eating Boston Market like
you know with my hands and and you know
and then and then and how during you
know hundreds of you know a team of
hundreds who are looking up at you it's
like a really scary thing and they all
assume that you I thought you met your
dream was walking into the office of
hundreds of people in your bathroom and
it's like that's very wolf of Wall
Street I got I kind of like that visual
like eating lobster tails while you walk
through the office I would totally I
would do that should I start over
because I didn't make them
no no no no that it does make sense I
mean how what did you view your now you
are you are no longer CEO is that
correct yes correct when you were CEO
what did you view is your job like as
entrepreneurs to you it's really tough
because there's so many things that I've
been a part of and done over the course
of the company's history and I'm also
kind of the brand the brand cop the
brand is my voice the vision is kind of
growing out of the the beginnings the
DNA of what was Nasty Gal
origin story so there's never been a
point where I could just be like the
cut-and-dry I'm the CEO kind of person
you know I'm the cultural leader and the
all of these things it was so many
things so you know when when you're when
you're growing a business it's really
hard to say no I'm not gonna plug that
hole I'm not going to edit the photos
I'm not gonna you know company spring
leaks and when you have when you've done
so many different things it's it's easy
to sprout arms and fingers and just
start like you know overextending
yourself by filling in the gaps as they
present themselves over the course of
you know so it was it was not I don't
think I got to choose my what I did as
much as I perhaps would have liked to
and I'm even today I'm not I'm not sure
if I have that privilege because you
kind of have to do what the company
needs you to do for it to continue
operating or to be it's very best in
nine years of that is a really long time
and I think my greatest strengths are
with the brand and with with marketing
the brand and with the creative and the
things that in the beginning we built
built Nasty Gal and that's what I'm
hoping I can focus on today how do you
how do you keep try to keep the team on
the same page so that that sort of brand
aesthetic and spirit doesn't get
fragmented and turned into some
Frankenstein monster where you've become
brands that you loathe or whatever you
get how do you
how do you Stratus do that you can
really quickly become a caricature of
yourself like yeah like yeah like a
spoof of like what you've done best and
I think it's about it's a matter of
talent but it's also coaching but at the
end of the day I think you really need
to have tools that everyone can rally
around and say hey this is what it is
this is what the brand is this is what
we're all signing up to do not this is
my idea versus your idea versus your
idea because I think culture like in a
you know in a in a business that people
really excited are excited to work at
culture can be used as a weapon I think
the brand can be used as a weapon
I think there you know there have been
times where people who are really cool
and actually do get what the brand is
find themselves really frustrated
because not everybody gets it the way do
they do and they start to say well Sofia
Sofia said this or Sofia wouldn't like
that and it's like I don't want to be
don't sling me around like that's not
cool and so we've been spending the last
several several months actually working
on somewhat of a brand Bible but also
just filters for how we make decisions
about what the voice is and how we how
we take pictures and you know the world
that is the Nasty Gal world and what the
you know what the guardrails are that
people can explore within we always want
to leave room for people to be creative
but it takes out a it takes out the the
objectivity or way yeah the the
subjectivity oh my god my brains not
working basically it makes it not
personal
so yeah it makes it makes it more
objective or depersonalized
yeah so it's easy for it to be like oh
well that's not on-brand because i said
so it's like oh hey we're all trying to
do the same thing let's look at this
thing that sits outside of us and our
taste our ego whatever let's talk about
what it is rather than what we think it
is so you have to have those things
defined for people to have conversations
about and that's something I'm really
excited to have there's a there's a
really cool hand book I think
just called the handbook for new
employees for a company called valve
which is a software company it's one of
the coolest sort of employee orientation
handbooks that I've ever seen I had a
chance to meet because Gabe Newell at
one point in Seattle and I was somebody
else then recommended I see this
handbook it's really cool you should
check it out I think you might enjoy it
and people listening might get something
out of it you can find the free PDF if
you just search valve employee handbook
it's pretty sweet I think I've seen that
it's really beautiful it's this teeny
little cool thing yeah yeah it's really
well done great illustrations but lays
out the basic ground rules right for
working within this somewhat unusual
culture that you mentioned the before I
derailed us with the wolf of Wall Street
analogy and you walking around in a
bathrobe eating lobster tails haha which
actually I have two quick quick anecdote
so when I was in college one of my
buddies and I was in I was in New Jersey
and one of my buddies ends up calling us
from Atlantic City and he's like there
are limos coming to get you you have to
come to Atlantic City we show up and
he's just been on a bender and made like
$200,000 blackjack and proceeds to spend
it all in the next 48 hours and he was
walking around the casino in a bathrobe
eating any ordered lobster tails for
everyone on the bundle like blackjack
store so I was kind of imagining like
you could you could be that person but
with like a martini glass just doing
absurd things like that because you can
like that so I was gonna ask you about I
was gonna ask you about managing and I
will but absurd things what are some
absurd things that you've done oh my
gosh I'm getting on a bus the cult that
I'm calling a girl bus hashtag girl bus
and well it's like later at the end of
this month and we're it's just the
paperback it's the girl boss paperback
and it has a new introduction and it's
the introduction to the introduction I
guess just talking about what's happened
over the last year a little bit and
we're going to like ten different cities
on this crazy tour bus it's like I'm a
spice girl or something and that's what
you know throwing events at different
venues and some bookstores and it's just
like it's really absurd to be riding
around like Hillary Clinton and I'm like
a campaign bus basically but penguin
penguin wanted to do it and I thought it
was just like too good to pass up and
it's really funny to have your face and
the covered your book like like you know
slathered across the side of like a
giant tour bus imagine what about
managing let's talk about that so the
managing of people you had no experience
prior to Nasty Gal now it's grown of
course tremendously what were who are
the mentors or what were the things that
helped you learn to manage to the extent
that you were able oh my god I think I'm
still learning wait say that again yeah
that was that was a word salad question
Wow who are the mentors or like the
resources that helped you learn to
manage other people because I think
that's a weakness of mine quite frankly
I'm good at defining systems but I'm not
always for instance I mean I was raised
by or not raised by that's weird I was
coached by a lot of athletic coaches who
were always kind of very short with
praise they would they would not they
didn't do a lot of head Pat's mhm but
heavy on criticism and very meticulous
and so I am often very bad at providing
praise when I probably should because I
don't feel like I was ever given it
therefore it's not really necessary I
think I'm saying but that causes all
sorts of problems right like we don't
feel appreciate it and it's like oh my
god I totally appreciate you but like I
respect your intelligence enough not to
like be like I don't know it's just it's
tough I mean because I've always been
told by luck the good cuff the good
stuff I remember I had a VP of Sales at
one point when my first job at a college
and he said you know
I would give him all the story in the
back sir tell him all this stuff about a
recline he's like Tim I don't need the
story I just need to know next steps and
second I don't need to know the good
news because that takes care of itself I
need to know the bad news and I was like
oh okay and so I've kind of adopted that
but you end up in a position where
people can get very demoralized in in a
culture where people aren't getting the
or don't have the ability to celebrate
little wins and so on who who has helped
you to become a better CEO when you were
CEO or a better manager I've had some
executive coaches along the way I think
knowing the difference and then actually
living the difference are two different
things and I think I'm pretty aware of
the things that I'm that what my
shortcomings are as a manager as a
leader as a fill-in-the-blank I'm not
you know I think I if experienced the
same thing where when you are especially
if your entrepreneurial which I think we
kate we can books like safely say we are
no one's giving you no one's giving you
those Pat's on the back and when you
find yourself in a position to be doling
those out you don't you don't really
relate because that's not something that
you ever required I'm an only child and
a really mean dad and he's awesome now
but like it was criticism after
criticism and it makes you self-aware
enough to to calibrate on your own in a
lot of ways even though I'm totally open
to I love you know criticism and I love
but I think when you when you're like a
solo act at any point in your life and
have to manifest things without without
the team without the amazing team that
we have today you become really good at
being your own critic and your own and
also your own pat on the back or you're
motivated maybe by different things and
that's a hard thing to relate to as an
entrepreneur who's leading who's leading
people and I think that's definitely
been one of my shortcomings but I'm
always like seeking advice and I'm
always thinking it better myself I think
leadership management chops whatever you
want to call it is something that comes
over time a lot of things are just
learned over time with repetition and
that's something that I have you know
I've been that's one part of the job
that I've had is managing people leading
people but there's been a million other
things that I've done
over the course of you know nasty gals
trajectory and having someone like
Sheree our CEO who has a lifetime of
those chops behind her who wakes up
every day inspired not just inspired to
lead people but knows how to do it in a
way that will work is such a real it's
such a cool thing to witness and when
when you were in the CEO role who were
the other CEOs out there alive or dead
that you admired and really looked to as
role models hmm good question I mean
I've always admired Natalie Massenet who
founded net-a-porter and it hasn't been
the CEO for a long time
but she's just like an incredible woman
why is she incredible um she's she's a
mother of I too uh she started a company
a long you know like she started an
e-commerce business long before most of
us had the idea to she's been told you
know I mean I think people like kind of
scoffed when she you know she said I'm
gonna sell a $30,000 handbag on the
internet or sell shoes on the internet
or these things that have become really
commonplace and she's also just a
super-duper down down earth woman who's
funny and sweet and gives great advice
and who's seen a lot and there's not
there's not a ton of examples that I
think are similar to hers Mickey Drexler
is also an incredible like yeah Mickey
Drexler yeah do you know who Mickey
Drexler I don't I'm embarrassed to say
oh my god but I shan't tell the lie okay
he's the he's the CEO at j.crew right
now and he used to be the CEO at Gap and
he's kind of like a retail legend he's I
think he's called like the merchant
Prince or merchant King or something
like that it's cool it's cool nickname I
know right I know he's just he's someone
who's giving me advice along the way
just really great advice and connecting
me to people that I've ended up you know
great people beget great people and you
know it's just when you meet someone
awesome you eat off its its
it's common that I find that the people
that they surround themselves with the
people that I also like and that's it's
just such a cool thing it's like I don't
know it's a you don't have to it's like
it's like going to never mind wait wait
no no I want you to finish that thought
that was about interesting I was gonna
start babbling like about Yelp reviews
and it's like it's like a jump review
for a person and it's just it was not an
intelligent thought so I you know I
should learn to do that more often
though to embarrass myself a lot less
it's what we're what what was some of
the advice that Mickey has given you
that that is stuck with you doesn't have
to be specifically business could be
anything
I mean his advice was to stay CEO which
is really funny it's definitely stuck
with me but I ignored it oh I can give
you an escape hatch for this my memory
blows yeah we can we can again I can
give you a whole slew of of pills and
potions for that but we will do that
separately the have you met David Choe
no you haven't
okay somebody asked online what you what
you learned from him yeah yeah the the
the graffiti artist slash artist who
ended up I guess worth 500 million after
Facebook I believe I'm saying his last
name oh that's cool but you haven't met
him what I learned about him was
everything that you just told me I
forget okay got it
yeah I've been hoping to I find his
story fascinating so I'm hoping to to
connect with him at some point it yeah
he just made some really fascinating
creative decisions that I'd love to love
to dig into but anyway that's a whole
separate story the what what do you
struggle with the most and how do you
deal with it I struggle with doing it
all most I struggle with feeling like I
don't have time for everyone who I want
to have time for and who I
I assume wants my time for my friends
and for my husband and for my parents
and for my team it's just time is a
really finite thing and prioritizing it
so that you can you know so you can be
your best so that you can you know have
a real solid time with people so you can
also find time to be alone or to take a
vacation it's just there's not enough
time so I'm always feeling like I'm
letting someone down or I'm just you
know it's like it's like my calendar is
booked up for the next month and a half
now and it's just I it's it's not always
like that but to look out at the rest of
the year it's kind of like it's over
like the year so you know years over
that's that's something I don't know I
you know I kind of hope that my life
isn't always like that but there's it's
got to be great things if you're
planning that far out I guess you know I
feel very lucky for that answered your
question really is is feeling like I
don't have all the time I wish I had to
spend with all the people that I wish I
could spend it with yeah
how do I deal with that yeah how do you
deal with it and let me ask just a in
combination with that and this is maybe
a very silly question
you obviously are very driven and that
sometimes leads people to find it
difficult to hit the the pause button or
downshift but you've stepped out of the
CEO role I would think as an outsider
looking in of course you're still going
to be very involved as as chairman is
chairman but why can't you create more
time why can't you block out of time
because the company still needs me for
my things and I still partner with my my
CEO and still spend a lot of time with
her
you know I'm drumming up opportunities
for the business whether it's a
collaboration or you know weighing in on
on something creative you know I still
spend time there you know I I've signed
up for more things that then I probably
should have but you know I I everyone
should be so I don't know I feel i feel
like saying no is just it doesn't create
opportunity so I'm throwing all that I
and into the air and just to see how
much I can actually handle I think I
don't know I might like their glutton
for punishment so you know it's like I'm
launching a podcast next month I'm like
promoting this paperback I'm finished
you know I'm working on another book I'm
like who knows I mean I want girlboss to
become its own thing the world boss
should be is is so much more than a book
it should be a business it should be it
should be conferences it should be it
should be so many things beyond what it
what it is it's just a matter of doing
it of making making the time and finding
the team and oh my god what am I going
to start another business I'm not sure
you know but just doing doing all I can
with all that I have and connecting
things that shouldn't connect is what
really really gets me excited because
that's where you would that's where
invention happens and that's that's
where I get that's where I just get like
really really excited about things so
what what were some of the key
inflection points for for the company so
if you look back over the last 10 years
or whatever it is what were some of the
key inflection points that allowed nasty
out to become what it is right that
because I can think back for instance
with the 4-hour workweek I can think
very specifically like the day that
Robert Scoble at the time put something
on his blog was a clear inflection point
that was a clear inflection point the
appearance on dr. Oz clear inflection
point meeting certain people getting
advice from say Michael Gerber who wrote
the e-myth revisited and before I even
wrote the 4-hour workweek he said if
you're gonna write a book write a
[ __ ] book like don't half-ass it
because a mediocre book is more of a
liability than a help and blah blah blah
right so so I can point to very clear
introductions meetings well what are
some of those four for you and nestea oh
yeah I would say it was launching I mean
the first one would be just launching
the eBay store
the next one would be selling a Chanel
jacket that I bought for $8 for over a
thousand
the next one would probably be launching
launching the website and having it sell
out just overnight and then pretty soon
after that hiring my first employee
after that it would be buying things
that weren't vintage so buying a small
medium and large of something from a
trade show and bringing in new brands
and testing and seeing if her customer
had an appetite for more than just
vintage which they did and then it was
like I think just didn't just you know
skate scaling isn't that's not a that's
not an inflection point but what
happened we outgrew our space in Benicia
I mean we've moved so many times but I
would say after that it was raising 50
million dollars from Index Ventures for
me personally it was four pages in
Forbes in 2012 how did the four pages in
Forbes happen because there's often some
back story right not not all of them are
just gifts from heaven that get dropped
and you're not that maybe this was but
how did that come together I mean that's
a that's a significant wait how did one
drop in my lap no how did it come
together I'm not saying it did Lauren
you're not the Forbes yeah um
oh my god the way the way media works is
what was it was it was someone who I had
met through index
her name was Julie soup and she was
friends with someone who wrote at Forbes
and they were getting brunch and she
mentioned me and this reporter got
interested and then I had no idea what I
was doing and never talked to the media
before and then Julie Julie used to run
on like PR at YouTube and she consults
for for startups and she's kind of like
a maestro of all things publicity and
she was like well now that you have
someone writing a profile on you in
Forbes you you you probably need my help
so I I don't know anyway she did a great
job and you know so I hired her and she
helped me helped me just coach me
through it she was like they're gonna
want you to look like a billionaire
that's that's their you know we've had
to reshoot other stuff that I've worked
on Forbes because they didn't think that
the entrepreneur and his hoodie looked
like a billionaire so it's so funny it's
really funny just how old that works and
so now I show up at photo shoots and I'm
like what do you want me to be okay I'm
bringing it you know it's like so dorky
but you know it's like whatever I just
try to do your but you do your best what
was that was that like that was cool
what was what were some other pieces of
advice that you got or things you've
learned about interacting with media god
I learned so much I feel like I'll give
one always do fact-check Corrections via
email and not phone yeah you need a
paper trail of that stuff I've been miss
miss quoted so many times and then that
will sneak its way into Wikipedia and
then it's a big big quagmire to fix I
mean I think it's just that like the
media always wants something to talk
about and they can they can skew things
or their own you know for their own fun
and it's you know there was a time where
I think I believed a lot of what I read
out there and I still believe a lot of
it but when there's controversy it's
often just to serve you know cliques and
you know get yeah I don't know it's like
I don't know I'm just kind of babbling
but be careful with what you say
and if you don't have anything to say
then just don't say anything I think
it's okay to say no yeah definitely
and also I mean one thing that I've
learned cuz if you take something out of
contacts like one sentence out of a
paragraph it can make you look like you
know a hero or a complete ass or a
misogynist or an [ __ ] or any number
of things so the context is so important
you know what I've been doing for the
last couple of years if I send a
response via email to a journalist I'll
just say thank you for using this in its
entirety I do not give permission to
slice and dice this if it's going to be
cut down I need to give you permission
and not everybody responds well to that
but usually the ones who respond poorly
to that if it's diplomatically worded
are the people who already had an agenda
to slant something in a really
controvert unnecessarily sort of a
incendiary wave and even like the most
you know the best some of the best
journalists I've worked with they'll
write a really positive story and then
their throat they'll throw in some [ __ ]
just for their own credibility to make
sure they don't sound like some big fan
yeah so there's always gonna be some
[ __ ] that they like say that you're
gonna be like grumpy about but it makes
them credible and you just kind of have
to like stomach it yeah and you can
actually I mean you can help them also
you can Silvia things by saying like
here two or three of my detractors but
that'll that can also give you as long
as they're safe actual attackers like an
ogre in heels and it's like um no like
I've like go-go-go danced in public in
[ __ ] heels I'm pretty sure I can it
was just like no like it's fine but like
of all the things like I can walk in
heels okay just like something just
there's plenty of things to criticize
Jesus if you if you catch me in like a
you know in the corner I'm probably
picking my nose like yeah it's just like
find something real when are you when
are you happiest god I'm happiest when
I'm like running down a trail in Big Sur
downhill a little just a little downhill
like any jump and you feel like you fly
like 20 feet it's almost like a dream um
yes I think that's the best feeling is
being like I'm in a video game but it's
real like this is real life and I'm it's
like yeah I think just like running down
a trail in the forest is like maybe the
best feeling ever
that's such a good answer that's a
carpenter uh do you side note if you
come back to San Francisco I'm sure
that'll happen at some point there's a
place called House of air which is
basically a humongous building full of
trampolines at different angles and you
can feel like you're in the matrix it's
amazing do you struggle with depression
or anything
like that and you don't have to amend
oppression my whole life I've been in
and out of therapy my whole life they
tried to tell me I had a needy and give
me some stuff in high school and they
tried to give me the stuff for
depression it's make me made me feel
super wired I I think when I got busy
that went away more than anything I
think I started with anxiety so I I can
hit the ceiling by like 11:00 a.m. if
something just doesn't go right I mean I
don't like to yell or pound my fists I'm
not like a person in the office who
throws things but if I'm like if I'm not
happy ain't nobody happy like in the
room basically it's just kind of like
it's not so I don't I'm not good at like
hiding my feelings it's it's unfortunate
and then there's people who value it and
I try to keep those people around but
you had depression depressions like a
gnarly gnarly thing how do you how do
you contend with that and I asked as
someone who has similar ups and downs
and has for as long as I can remember
but what do you what are your coping
mechanisms if it's you know I it's easy
to point at things in your life that are
out of your own control like I've
pointed that who I got married like
three months ago but I there's been
times where I pointed at Joel and I was
like you're the problem it's like no
you're just not you're not solving your
own problems like I think you can just
look everywhere outside of yourself to
fix your problems and thank God I'm not
like I don't know it's like addiction
issues or anything because I'm totally
if that was if I was that ran in my
family I'd be a total mess I think I do
know that I've been I've taken
antidepressants at different times and
some are better than others but I just I
generally like to stay pretty kind of I
know alcohol alcohol can help yeah yeah
that's so I I'm not I'm gonna lose more
now though but I mean I can have one
glass of wine and I'm like
the happiest most like like charismatic
like you know just fun person went and a
few says yeah and what I'm not drinking
I'm like you don't want to walk up and
talk to me like I'm not friendly
like I'm not unfriendly I'm just not
open you know I'm just kind of like
stuck in my head you know I don't know
what what's your go-to wine drink or
your go-to one yeah I like white wine a
lot of bars don't have white wine but it
would just be like I don't know I
started drinking chardonnays I like
those oh I got a Gewurztraminer this is
really good right it's really good very
mint mineral a good one is the cliff
family cliff bar people I went to this
thing in Napa oh my god so I sound like
so cool now but I took a I like going on
a bike ride it was basically my my
investors have a retreat every year and
all of their entrepreneurs and and
they're in the in the partners at their
firm get together and this is at the
cat-cows ERG ranch which is like the
really beautiful place in Napa gorgeous
super should be pretty fancy and then
they had these activities you know so
you don't hear people talk and there's
really cool people like Jerry Yang spoke
at the last one and just it's it's
really interesting and then they have
this you know these activities and one
of them was you know road biking and
road biking up to a winery and then
having a glass of wine I was like yeah
I'm getting shape for my wedding like
I'm gonna drink wine and I should get on
a bike first rate and oh my god these
all these guys they're all European for
one and they're like you know they're
like wealthy guys who like have their
own shoes and like all the clothes and
like do this all the cycling said
they're like $5,000 take take it was
like I was just like going on a bike
ride for fun and I was just oh my god it
was the only person that like didn't
finish it I did get in the car and like
get a ride to the top of the hill anyway
in the top of the at the top of the hill
was cliff family winery I don't know why
I'm like I'm like I don't know them I'm
not I'm sorry
not trying up like plug anything I was
just like I never heard of
Gewurztraminer and I bought a few
bottles into it and like had it shipped
to my house and um yeah I guess I guess
a white Krispy wine yeah super that's
super tasty stuff son Sarah's pretty
good go-to for a lot of folks the I
guess I usually do it gin tonics of
Hendrix and Hendrix and soda it's kind
of my go-to if I uh don't want to have a
nasty nasty headache or tequila as
you've seen you have to you have to go
with the good stuff if you're gonna do
tequila so the cost of that I gonna is
very expensive but very tasty with that
no head I mean you saw me I had a fair
amount to drink but no headache the next
day no cognitive dysfunction felt just
fine the when you think of the word
successful and I know that's a gnarly
dicey word but who's the first person
who comes to mind for you yeah
successful the word success is really
completely conflicted for me because it
sells people this idea that there's like
a destination I think there's people who
can man have manifested things that in
the world that make more noise than
other people but success can just be
like being a stay-at-home mom if that's
your dream success can be having a small
business and keeping it that way and
keeping in laying low because that's
what you want and that's the life that
you want I really want you know and as
someone whose public it's kind of like a
it's a it's a it's a hairy thing because
I'm not there and I'm I have a book and
you know I have a business and I fell
things and whatever but it's I just
really want people to remember that
they're capable of doing everything that
the people they admire are doing maybe
not everything but if you're oh don't be
so impressed I guess that's where you
know where where my head goes is you
know there's no reason that you can't
have the things that the people that you
admire that you admire have and so
success just sells this kind of like
ultimate destination when even though
I've accomplished something and you've
accomplished something whatever it's
like you I I told you I was crying last
night it's not like we who like my you
know I'm done I've arrived or anything
like that if you have any amount of
hustle and any amount of humility you
know that it all can go away tomorrow
and that you should do everything you
can with that knack with what you have
to today so I guess it's a very
philosophical way of saying when I hear
the word success I don't know what
Warren Buffett I don't you know like I
don't know it's tough yeah it's a tough
one you said don't ask the cobbler if
you're a bricklayer or whatever I was
thinking of Warren Buffett when you said
that because he often says don't ask a
barber if you need a haircut
the let me ask just a couple of rapid
for our questions you don't have to have
rapid-fire answers but just because I
know that people will ask me why I
didn't ask them if I leave them out what
is your favorite document or your movie
my favorite movie might be a film called
the color the color of pomegranates and
it's by this guy circus or gay Parajanov
I'm not even sure if I pronounced it
correctly he was like a Georgian
filmmaker and it's basically a moving
painting it's just one of the most
there's almost no dialogue it's just one
of the most beautiful films I've ever
seen and I've been you know I grew up
Greek Orthodox and I'm just still kind
of enchanted with the with Eastern the
visuals of like Eastern Europe yeah
since sounds gorgeous I need to sort of
fill up my roster so I'll add that to
the list
what do you world-class at that people
might not realize or what are your
friends know your world class at that
the rest world doesn't know about wait
what do I put on my thingy I don't know
I didn't read it so for those people
listening I I send I could look it up I
send some of these questions in advance
just so people don't get totally stumped
which happens but I didn't look at the
answers because I want it to be fresh
for conversation I could pick it up I
could pick it up bear with me a second
I'll pick it up oh my god I can use my
brain oh that's okay that's okay it's
let's see we got plane catch oh my god
yeah yeah I guess plane catch yeah no
I'm like I I can't have really good
coordination to the point of it like
being freaky like if I drop something I
can be like looking the other direction
like scratching my armpit with one hand
and then like like swoop in and like
cat-like reflexes like that happens
sometimes but it always beauty even
surprises me
and also I'm good at playing catch
do you have did you play athletics as or
sports growing up or no yeah I played
soccer I mean I played basketball I
played softball when I was like in third
grade and then I played soccer a lot my
snowboarded a lot
Inever hacky sack San Francisco awaits
we can every can do some like hula
hooping I could teach it I could give
some basics we could do six stepping
next time you come along what are the
most common misconceptions about you um
oh I think people well I've met some
people yesterday who thought they were
like I was like what is that what it's
what surprises you must we spent some
time and I showed them the office and
talked to them about my business and I
was like well you know what do you what
surprised you and they said well you're
you're you're not as egotistical as I
thought you'd be and say wow I mean it's
not insulting you put money outside you
know you put yourself on the cover of a
book with their hands on your hips and
you know whatever and you maybe you
expect something different but that was
that was plot that was a pleasant
respond yeah it's better than the other
way around like wow you're so much more
mega maniacal then I couldn't God get me
away from you
if you could have a billboard anywhere
with anything on it more what it's
saying where would you put it I could
have a billboard I put nothing on it and
I put it everywhere just an empty bowl
boy you know I'm gonna cheat here I'm
gonna go back and see if there's
anything else that you'd stop telling
women to smile yeah that's just like
such a grumpy billboard though I changed
my mind
I have nothing you project what you want
onto the film board but I guess that's
that's and since I've given you this
this imaginary billboard you're entitled
to do that but I want to hear the back
story and stop telling women to smile
what's the what's the what's the story
back story
well it's something that I've said I
mean I've said just like don't tell me
to smile or like I mean if you're a girl
who's not like who a guy wants to talk
to and you intimidate them because you
aren't like giggling or whatever they'll
like take a it's like your ears were
there for your we're there for your
pleasure I don't know what it is but
it's happened to me from as early as I
can remember just like you should smile
more just like oh you look really pretty
when you smile and it's like that's nice
thanks but there's something that's like
you're you're here for me so can you
just smile if I have to like look at you
you know cuz you're making like a woman
a woman evaluating me just makes me feel
like I'm askew lated or something kind
of you know like they just like don't
know how to handle it and it's really
frustrating and honestly pretty
insulting and then I found out that
there's a woman named what is her name
I mean she has like this you an artist I
think she's in Brooklyn and she started
something called stop telling women to
smile and someone's telling me about the
other day and her name is Tatiana fuzz
Louise fuzz lolis Depp oh my god
Fazlu ELISA day I think it's a tough
that's just her a long name I'm I'm
embarrassed of how I did that but she
has like a like wheat paste posters and
like kind of like a campaign like stop
telling a living to smile like I'm not
your baby that kind of [ __ ] which is
just I wouldn't put you know it's
if I could put one thing in a billboard
it would probably be nothing
maybe Nasty Gal if it was free you know
yeah what what was your what was your
thinking process around stepping down
stepping out of the CEO role yeah yeah I
just my things that I find myself that I
think I'm good at they're not the things
that a CEO wakes up every day to do run
running an executive team of sea-levels
who have more experience you know then
I've been in you know then then I've
been in business for or it's just it's
like there's a like I said earlier
there's just a totally different skill
set that comes with leading leading
people and and giving praise and
repeating what you're there what we're
all here to do there's a lot of
repetition actually and I'm the kind of
person that's like what you didn't hear
me the first time which is not I'm not
saying I'm proud of that I just think
that's kind of how I that's just like
how I roll and I you know I it's a hole
if there's an art to leadership and yeah
I want it I wanted to focus on the
creative parts of the business you know
I want you know the book kind of had its
own it kind of made me the face of the
company which I wasn't prior and so
there's things that come along with that
that are good for Nasty Gal but take my
time and take me out of your office and
there's nothing worse than feeling like
you're you've abandoned the people who
are reporting to you who need your time
it's just a matter of choosing so I you
know I chosen it was something that had
been not I've been thinking about for a
long time what was what was the first
day like or a night after you made the
decision and it was you'd finally kind
of made the call and knew that you were
no longer gonna be CEO I think it was
just a lot of relief a lot of relief and
just feeling I had done the right thing
I was really happy for sherry my CEO and
it just seemed kind of like a non-event
to our team I expected more of a
reaction but they were like what's the
difference Sherry's in all its uh All
Hands meetings and she speaks we know
who she is what step of it I don't think
it was a huge change for most of our
team which felt good
yes yeah that's great
that's huge that's a big yeah I expected
a lot more questions and I was kind of
bummed that people weren't they weren't
like they weren't like they look like
freaked out they're like okay cool
we've been waiting for years don't let
the door hit you on the way I'm just
kidding what $100 or less purchase has
most positively impacted your life in
recent memory I had a hamburger
yesterday hamburger
what kind of what kind of burger where I
mean was it a particularly uh-huh
interesting I don't know I mean the one
thing I mean I could fit yeah let me I
can think harder on this but yeah it's
basically just inexpensive stuff that
you get a lot of value I think I'm
looking at my I mean a manicure
manicurists are like pretty they're good
they're like they make you feel better
but they cost like you know I get gels
so I don't know maybe they're like 20 or
30 bucks and you don't hate your hands
as much I don't know what else
um under $100 not a lot as under $100
it's like a hamburger or you know
probably I mean probably a glass of wine
oh my god
that's for theme here it's a glass none
glass why it's good I actually bought
one of my favorite bottles of wine I've
ever had
I bought from Trader Joe's they have
great wine service I mean the people
really know what they're talking about
it's for $4 for a bottle of white wine
and if you want to upgrade that you get
the I really like Rombauer shark good
yeah 2004 I think I had which was
amazing
and not that expensive that was the
first white wine I ever bought a case of
I thought I would never buy a case of
white wine ever I've always been a red
wine guy and robbed our Chardonnay was
the one that made the difference what is
what is the first 60 minutes of your day
look like now I'm gonna ask that a
little retrospectively when you were CEO
of the company on a on a on a on a day
where you look back and you're like [ __ ]
yeah kicked ass today what did the first
60 to 90 minutes of your day look like
or what were your morning routines yeah
I mean I usually and a day that ends
well is when it started with exercise
that's for sure mm-hmm
I usually eat you know for breakfast so
I wake up what time what time do you
wake I don't know like 6:30 7:00 most
people are like exercising at 6:30 or
7:00 but I'm just I don't know I I stay
up I'm like I keep I I just keep great
hours so I wake up I take my Invisalign
out of my mouth because I sleep with
these braces and basically and before
that it was a mouth guard because I
clench my teeth because I'm a freak but
I recently Botox my jaw so that I can't
clench my teeth as much whoa sweet you
injected fat like not your mountable
spats just something that basically
makes your muscle weaker so dad you like
don't aren't such a I'm like I'm like
Hulk smash like I've clenched my teeth
like the [ __ ] Hulk
oh no I I sometimes like wake up with
blow my god punching I'll just by
looking at your face that's what I've
like really over developed jaw muscles
like a pitbull I do let me look at hold
on let me look a right now no but it
does that's what happens you know I have
a jaw muscle that no you don't yeah I
don't have a strong jaw but when you're
a girl that was like a kind of a
masculine thing whatever but yeah I'd
also just you wake up with a headache so
I did that that helped that I think
that's helping actually yeah and then I
wake up i prime it-- P I I chug water
I'll try a bunch I try to chug a bunch
of water but it don't always
and then I drink coffee with heavy cream
in it what how do you make your coffee
we have a thing called a Jarrah like a
Jay you are a some company and it's just
like basically you put the beans in and
it grinds them and it's just a coffee
maker I guess but it's like a fancy
coffee maker Jay you are a you are a
yeah
and but I put I put hot water in the
glass I feel that fill the mug up about
half way with hot water and then I put
the shots of coffee
I guess it's espresso I don't know or
coffee beans and espresso beans the same
thing they are often roasted slightly
differently but my understanding is
you're just using kind of more beans for
the volume in the case of espresso but
that but the darker the roast is my
understanding is the lower the caffeine
is interestingly enough but but yeah
you're basically making in America we
use David Lynch coffee if you haven't
tried it it's pretty David Lynch like
yes he had his own coffee are you
serious say he not he not only has
transmittal meditation foundation in
schools for a tricky at-risk youth he
also has his own wow man I'm really
listening but he also has his own coffee
looking fabulous coffee I just did it's
pretty good that's I don't know my
husband found it but and then I see you
have your coffee with with why heavy
cream I don't know someone told I'm a
big fan of anything better for your
stomach and now the whole thing is that
like fat good for you so I care even
less but I already knew that so yeah and
then I'll have one of maybe three things
I have rolled oats with a little bit of
honey and a little bit of milk and a
little bit of salt with raisins usually
just made on the stovetop and then or I
will have a pancake that I make out of
rolled oats so I crack four egg whites
into a bowl and then I put two cups of
dry rolled oats in and then I stir it
around and the eggs kind of help the
oats congeal and
yeah and then I shape it into a pancake
in a pan and then I cook I like heat it
up a little bit and then I put it on a
plate and I put apple sauce on it
and a little bit of maple syrup and I
eat it and it's really good that sounds
amazing
it's I mean but it's two ingredients
which is crazy and it's it it looks it
doesn't look as good as it tastes it's
pretty decent
it's I bet that would be really good
with like some nuts oh yeah or I eat
drink like a white smoothie which is
like has Apple and the Greek yogurt and
some cinnamon and it's just like a
pretty simple but so some of that stuff
some of those recipes came from this guy
that I trained with named Harley
Pasternak have you heard of him I have
heard that name yet isn't this a he
trains with UFC fighters what am I
making
he's like a celebrity trainer type and
he has people that work for him and I
most oh you know what I'm thinking about
Mike Dolce okay yes yes pastor but
Pasternak yup yeah he has some books and
stuff he's awesome and I just got on
some cool recipes from him so those are
his recipes and then I'll I don't know I
guess I shower you know and then are all
go work out you know depending sometimes
I do sometimes I don't and then start my
day sometimes I'll roll out of bed and
have a phone call and you know I you
know it's like we have a call we're on a
kind of like a call now and it's like I
haven't showered I don't know I'm at
home sometimes I'll have calls for a
while before I go in the office
sometimes I won't go in the office
because I'm working on something that I
need to focus on and that's hard to do
in the office and every day is different
but it they all start pretty much the
same when you work out what if you could
only choose a couple of exercises for
the rest of your life what would they be
and the reason I'm asking is I saw this
photograph on your Instagram account
which which I thought was hilarious and
a it was it was you honest I want to say
an elliptical and it said preparing the
center for her wedding day or something
like that yeah and because you have very
well very well developed pollutes put it
that way sure you think I have to
I know this is purely anatomical
speaking as a exercise physiologist and
so those don't look like they came from
ellipticals or is that just a god-given
that's I like I can't because what I
think no you're great in Greek Italian
and Portuguese all right that explains
okay so I thought I'd I knew only about
the Greek part I'm like not usually like
if it was like yes some 80 percent
Brazilian I did okay that makes no and
people actually like it surgery and make
their butts okay it's like if I wear a
dress like the top fits but then the bot
I can't get the bottom over my hips or
and then or if like if the hips fit and
like the top is too big and I'm not
gonna like I don't know I don't I don't
I don't want big boobs and then like if
I wear pants
it's just weird it's not it's it's like
it's it's weird that like our culture is
like in two bucks cuz I think they're
kind of gross but well I mean I think
you just have to watch like Discovery
Channel for 15 minutes and see like
presentation posture and all that stuff
and mammals have that fixation I think
but the not my intention to go there but
the exercises so if you're exercising
before you get started with the day you
can only pick a couple of exercises I
mean you basically asked me why I have a
big butt like that's what that's just
funny what do you do well if you had to
only choose a couple of types of
exercise not not just for the but what
would you not having a big butt is that
like it can go to hell really fast so
you have to you kind of have to exercise
um I do deadlift for my butt um I do a
lot of lunges I do some like walking
lunges and like some I don't know we do
squat sometimes I'll like resistance
training when you do deadlifts are you
doing sumo stance with your legs wider
your legs closer
they're kind of like shoulder um they're
a little beyond shoulder width and like
slightly bent right and and if you had
to choose three types of exercise just
for
the combination of like enjoyment and
benefits for you overall what would you
choose
probably like squat jumps box jumps and
let's see like shoulder presses I don't
know that seems like you could get a lot
it's like a lot of different things
happen with those three exercises right
and then you have the mountain you have
the trail running at a slight if I'm in
Big Sur yeah for the flying effect well
I only want to ask a couple more
questions and I will let you get back to
your day but this is this has been very
fun what did what advice would you give
your thirty year old self it doesn't get
easier
I need tell me more oh I don't know I
mean I think I think when you're you're
like yeah I'm like on to something my
business is growing and oh this is so
cool I can't wait for a time when you
know I can just like yeah let go or a
time where I can oh man this is just
gonna be running itself someday or I'm
gonna I don't know like or just you you
think um you know as you get older I
mean yeah you know more you can handle
things better but it's the same it's the
same you know it's just it's bull it's
just different stuff I guess and the
challenges are bigger with bigger things
and you know I think I think it's easier
just to sell yourself or for maybe other
people to sell you that it's just like
one vacation after the next and hey I
have great life I really appreciate
everything that I have and I've taken
some great vacations but just that like
that the the hustle never ends
you know but I was just a year ago I was
thirty a year ago so hmm
it would be like hi I don't know that's
all right I keep forgetting that you're
just you're such a youngin
what
what are you most looking forward to in
the next 12 months in the next 12 months
I'm looking forward to going to Tokyo
yeah we're going to Tokyo my husband and
I for like a week and I haven't been
since I was in high school and it's just
I know it's a cool place and I've some
memory of it but things are so different
when you're an adult and I'm excited to
check it out eat food now I hate sushi I
didn't eat sushi when I was in high
school
weird oh yeah now that opens up all
sorts of doors the well if you ever want
to chat about that oh yeah
just feel free to ping me yeah give it
give me a call I've spent a lot of time
there and actually have a two-part
article on Tokyo on the blog that goes
through some of the the smaller spots
that I love but that is exciting yeah we
can Tokyo is something I think everyone
should do it's one of those completely
alien places for English speakers where
you can get completely lost completely
confused even in the middle of the night
and not really be in any danger
whatsoever
yeah you can leave your purse you know
on like you can like give it to a bum
and it's probably say for an hour yeah
first check it's just a fascinating
fascinating country it forces you to
question a lot of your own so different
social norms and behaviors which i think
is really helpful so that's that is
exciting I'm super stoked for I'm gonna
be headed to Korea for the first time
I've only been in the airport the hope
linked to hoping to head to Seoul and
within the next month up to but what do
you have any ask or requests for my
audience and will will the question
after this is gonna be where they can
find you online and learn more about you
and so on but just in general any like
recommendation or request of my audience
any action they should take or things
they should think about yeah I don't
know compliment someone today
say something nice to someone be nice be
nice awesome
well I would love people to check out
what you're up to
you've done such you've done so much for
such a young and I think well that that
of course is a sort of high praise in my
my world but yeah you have to but where
can people learn more about you find out
what you're a cool
well Nasty Gal calm that's like you know
my reason for existing and then you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
snapchat it's Sofia underscore Amoruso
and I'm launching a podcast I don't know
launching a podcast next month called
girlboss radio and you can read my book
it's called girlboss cool yeah and
people will be listening to this for
quite a while so look for girlboss radio
gasp and the book has 835 reviews on
Amazon four and a half stars more than I
want to say I'm looking right here more
than 70 percent or five stars so the
book is at a fantastic reception and I
appreciate you
this episode is brought to you by Vimeo
Pro which is the ideal video hosting
platform for entrepreneurs and in fact a
bunch of my startups already use Vimeo
Pro including wealthfront who uses it to
explain how wealthfront works TaskRabbit
uses it to tell their company's story
and there are many other names you would
recognize among their customers Airbnb
Etsy etc why do they use it well Vimeo
Pro provides enterprise level video
hosting for a fraction of the usual cost
features include gorgeous high quality
playback with no ads up to 20 gigabytes
of video storage every week unlimited
plays and views and a fully customizable
video player which can include your logo
custom outro etc you also get VIP
support and you get all of this for just
$1.99 per year that's $17 a month with
no complicated bandwidth calculations or
hidden fees and you can try it risk-free
for 30 days so check it out Vimeo comm
forward slash business that's VI em yo
comm forward slash business and use
promo code Tim to get 25% off that's a
special discount just for you guys so
check it out de mio com forward slash
business promo code
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens I get asked all the time
if you could only use one supplement
what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day and you can get 50 oh my
gosh 50% off yes 50% off if you go to
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim check it out
it's tasty but more important it will
help you not screw up when you're doing
your nutritional plantings for me just
covers the bases takes a load off my
mind
puts a lot in my body and check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
and until next time thank you for
listening